howdy folks Maxwell here with another
gamespot news update today EA has
announced a new subscription service
that's going to give Xbox one users
access to select EA games the program is
called EA access and is available today
in beta for some users with a wider
launch plan soon for five dollars a
month or thirty dollars for an annual
subscription users get access to games
in the vault which currently contains
four games with more to be added later
the vault currently contains fifa 14
madden NFL 25 peggle two and battlefield
4 this is an Xbox one exclusive program
in a statement EA said we are always
looking for new ways to make it easier
for gamers to play more EA games across
all platforms and we are excited about
what EA access will offer two players on
Xbox one in addition to access to the
vault a subscription also gets you ten
percent off purchases of EA digital
content for Xbox one games through the
xbox games store although EA cautions
that conditions limitations and
exclusions apply another bonus should
the subscription is the ability to play
trial versions of new EA titles up to 5
days before their official release date
this will include several upcoming
sports games as well as dragon age
inquisition now this is a surprise
announcement by EA but we'll be
providing additional details as
information becomes available over on
gamespot com